We began the course by talking about
one of the foundational ideas of modern
psychology.
This is what a Francis Crick described
as the astonishing hypothesis.
The idea that our mental life,
our consciousness, our morality,
our capacity to make decisions
and judgments is a product
of a material physical
brain. What I want to talk
about today and introduce it,
it's going to be a theme that dough we're
going to continue throughout the rest
of the course is a second idea,
which I think is equally shocking,
perhaps more shocking.
Um,
and this has to do with we're mental
life comes from not necessarily its
material nature, but rather
its origin. And the notion,
this other astonishing hypothesis is
what the philosopher Daniel Dennett has
described as Darwin's dangerous idea.
Um,
and this is the modern biological account
of the origin of biological phenomenon
including psychological phenomena.
Now people have long been interested in
the evolution of complicated things and
there is an argument that's been repeated
throughout history and many people
have found it deeply compelling,
including Darwin himself.
Darwin,
as he wrote,
the origin of species was deeply persuaded
and move by this argument from in the
form presented by the
theologian William Paley.
So Paleo has an example here.
Paly tells,
gives the example of you're walking down
the beach and your foot hits a rock and
then you wonder where
did that rock come from?
And you don't really expect an
interesting answer to that question.
Maybe it was always there, maybe
it fell from the sky, who cares?
But suppose you found a watch on the
ground and then you ask where to watch had
come from.
Um,
Paly points out that it would not be
satisfying to simply say it's always been
there or it came there as an accident.
And he uses this comparison to,
to make a point,
which is a watch is a very
complicated and interesting thing. Um,
Paley is,
it was a medical doctor and Paly goes on
to describe a watch and compare a watch
to the eye and noticing that a
watch and I contain multitudes,
multitudes of parts that interact in
complicated ways to do interesting things.
In fact, to change and to update
the analogy a little bit. Um,
an I is very much like a machine
known as a camera. Um, and,
and,
and they're similar at a deep way.
They both have lenses that Ben
Light and project an image onto,
a light sensitive surface for the eye.
Light sensitive surfaces,
the retina for the camera to film.
Um,
they both have a focusing
mechanism, um, for the eye.
It's muscles that change the
shape of the Lens. Um, for,
for a camera it's a diaphragm that
governs the amount of incoming light. Um,
even they're both in Cayston
black, the light sensitive, uh,
part of the eye and part of the
camera are both in case than black,
the differences. So, so in fact,
the eye and a camera look a lot alike
and we know the camera is an artifact.
A camera has been constructed
by an intelligent,
by intelligent beings to
fulfill a purpose. In fact,
if there's any difference between things
like the eye and things like a camera,
um, the difference is that, um,
the things like the eye are far more
complicated than things like the camera.
And I was a kid. I had this incredible
TV show called the $6 million man.
Anybody here ever seen it or heard of it?
Anyway,
the idea is there's a test pilot,
Steve Austin and his,
his rocket jet crashes and
he loses his both legs,
his arm in his eye,
which sounds really bad,
but they replaced them with
bionic stuff with artificial leg,
artificial arm and an artificial eye that
are really super powered in any fights
crime. It was really the best
show on it was really good. Um,
but the thing is, this
was in 1974. It's now,
uh, over 30 years later and
it's true then is true now.
This is fantasy. It doesn't make it to the
level of science fiction. It's fantasy.
We are,
are impossibly far away from
developing machines that could do this.
We are impossibly far away from building
a machine that can do what the human
eye does. And so suddenly,
like Haley points that look,
the complexity of the biological
world suggests that these things are
complicated artifacts created
by a designer far smarter
than any human engineer.
And the designer, of course would be, God,
I went to Google images and I don't mean
that to be sacra religious in any sense.
I, you could try this. I went to
Google images and type in God,
and this was the showed up
right in the middle. Um,
so, and this, this paly argued it and
it was, it's been convincing throughout.
Most of history is, um, is,
is a perfectly logical explanation for
these complicated things come from. Um,
it also has the advantage
of being compatible with
scripture and compatible for
religious beliefs. But paly made
the point is, stands on its own.
If you find complicated things, um,
that, that, that complicated artifacts,
you don't assume they emerge by accident.
You assume that they were created
by an intelligent, uh, being.
Now this view has always had
problems. This view, you could,
you could call it creationism,
which is that biological structures
were created by an intelligent being has
always had problems. One problem
is it pushes back the question.
So you asked where did that
intelligent being coming from?
And this is a particularly serious problem
from the standpoint of evolution of
psychological structures.
So we want to know how is
it that creature's came
across upon this earth with
the ability to reason and plan and do
things and then the answer as well,
another creature with
that ability created us.
That doesn't necessarily mean it's wrong,
but it means it's unsatisfying.
You immediately want to get an explanation
for that other creature comes from.
Um, more to the point, there's
always been evidence for evolution.
And what I mean by evolution here
isn't necessarily a specific mechanism,
but merely the fact that
that body parts like the,
I didn't emerge all of a sudden,
but rather have parallels both within
other existing animals and across a human
and biological history.
Um, this, this, uh,
evidence comes in different forms.
There's fossil evidence for different
body parts cause suggesting that they have
evolved for more rudimentary form.
Um,
there is Vesta Joel characteristics
and what this means is there are
characteristics that human bodies have
that are somewhat inexplicably will,
um,
like the human tailbone or goosebumps
unless you've used them at the human body.
In this current form as modifications
from a previous form. Um,
there are parallels with other animals
and this is clear in psychology.
So human brain is different
from the rat cat monkey brain,
but at the same time you see them
following a sort of common plan and common
structures.
And one rational inference from this is
that they're linked through evolutionary
descent.
Um,
finally there's occasional poor design.
So paly rhapsodized about the remarkable
powers of the human body and the
different body parts.
But even paly admitted that there's some
things which just don't work very well.
You're, I contains a blind spot because
of how the nerves are wired up. Um,
the,
in the male urinary system,
the urethra goes through the prostate
gland, um, instead of around it,
which leads to many physical
problems in men later on in life. Um,
and so you're forced to s to either
argue that these are really good things,
um, or that God has either
malicious, aren't competent,
and those are difficult arguments to make.
So these are problems
with the creationist view,
but still for the longest time
in human intellectual history,
there was no alternative. And
in fact, so Richard Dawkins,
the most prominent evolutionary
biology and most prominent evolutionary
biologists alive,
and one of the most staunchest critics
of creationism has rewritten in the blind
watchmaker saying,
look,
anybody a hundred years ago or 150 years
ago who didn't believe that God created
humans and other animals was a moron.
Because the argument from
design is a damn good argument.
And in the absence of some other argument,
um,
you should go defer to that
and you should say, well,
there are all these problems,
but humans and other biological horns
must have divine creation because of their
incredible rich and intricate structure.
Um, what changed all that
of course was Darwin. Um,
and Darwin, um, is Darwin's
profound accomplishment.
We're showing how you get
these complicated biological
structures like the eye
emerging through a purely
non-intentional non created process.
I'm a purely physical process and this
could be seen as equal in importance to
the claim that the earth
revolves around the sun,
um, and that we're not the
center of the universe. So,
in fact, some scholars have,
have made, made a suggestion,
which seems plausible that the idea of
natural selection is the most important
idea in the sciences period.
So this is not a course on evolution and
expect people to have some background.
If you don't have a background in it,
you could get your background from, um,
from external readings,
but also from the grip.
The Gray textbook and the Norton
readings were both perfect.
We'll each provide you with enough
background to get up to speed.
But the general idea is that there are
three components to natural selection.
There's variation in this.
Variation gives rise to different degrees
of survival and reproduction and gets
passed on from generation to generation
and gives rise to adaptations.
What Darwin described as,
um,
that perfection of structure to
justly excites our imagination.
And the biological world
has all sorts of examples.
You look at camouflage prior to Darwin,
one might imagine that some intelligent
creator crafted animals to hide from
their prey,
but now we have a different alternative,
which is that animals that were
better at hidden, um, survive better,
reproduce more.
And over the course of thousands,
perhaps millions of years,
they develop elaborate camouflage.
There's been a lot of work on
Paley's favorite example, the eye.
So Darwin himself noted that the human
eye did not seem to emerge all at once,
but rather you can look at other animals
and find parallels and other animals.
It seemed to suggest that more
rudimentary forms are possible.
And more recently, um, computer
simulations have developed,
have been developed that
have crafted eyes, uh,
under plausible assumptions of
selective pressure. And, uh,
what the starting point is.
So this is the theory
of natural selection.
The good question to ask is why am I
talking about evolution in introduction to
psychology class?
And the answer is that there are two
ideas which come together and in fact
they're both of the dangerous
ideas. One idea is that that, um,
Darwin's idea that biological forms
evolve from this purely physical process.
The second idea,
um,
the rejection of Descartes is that our
minds are the product of physical things
and physical events.
You bring these together and it forces
you to the perspective that what we are,
our mental life is no less than I know
less than camouflage the product of this
purely physical process of natural
selection. More to the point,
um, our cognitive mechanisms
were evolved not to please God,
not as random accidents,
but rather for the purpose of
survival and reproduction. Um,
more contentiously you could argue they've
been shaped by natural selection to
solve certain problems.
And so from an evolutionary point of view,
when you look at what the brain
is and what the brain does,
you look at it in terms of these problems.
And this is what,
um,
this is what psychology is for. This
is what our thinking is for. Um,
we have evolved mental capacities
to solve different problems,
perception of the world,
communication, uh,
getting nutrition and rest and so on.
Now we're going to talk about how
to apply evolutionary theory to,
um, to psychology. But as we're doing so,
we have to keep in mind two misconceptions
are two ways you can go seriously
wrong here. The first
is to think that, well,
if we're taking an evolutionary approach,
the natural selection will cause
animals to want to spread their genes.
So if we're being biological about it,
that means everybody must run around
thinking, I want to spread my jeans,
I want us, you know, and, and um,
and this is just really, oops,
that shouldn't do that. This is really
wrong. Um, it's, it's even in red.
Uh,
and what this fails to do is make a
distinction between ultimate causation and
proximate causation.
And those are technical terms
referring to ultimate causation. Is,
is the reason why something's
there in the first place.
Over millions of years of history.
Proximate causation is why you're
doing it now. And these are different.
Um,
obviously for instance,
animals do all sorts of things
to help survive and reproduce,
but a cockroach doesn't think,
oh,
I'm doing this to help survive
and reproduce and spread my jeans.
A cockroach doesn't know
anything about jeans. Um,
rather the mechanisms
that make it do what it,
what it does are different
from its own mental states.
If it has any why it doesn't.
This is the point nicely made by William
James William James Ass. Why do we eat?
And he writes, not one man and a billion
when taking his dinner, everything.
So utility he eats because the food
tastes good and make someone more.
If you ask them why you should want to
do more of what tastes like that instead
of revering you as a philosopher,
he'll probably laugh at you for a fool.
And certainly the common sense answer,
why are you eating?
Nobody's going to answer because I must
sustain my body so as to spread my jeans
in the future.
Rather you eat because you're hungry.
Those two theories you eat because
you're hungry and you eat to sustain your
body. So you can spread your genes in the
future are not alternative rather than
different levels of explanation.
Um,
and you can't confuse them.
The ultimate level,
which does appeal to survival and
reproduction, there's not, um, is,
is independent from the
psychological level.
To give another example, um, people
protect their children. So you ask,
why do people protect their children?
Why would somebody
devotes so much effort to,
to protecting and helping and
feeding their children? Well,
the evolutionary explanation is animals
that don't protect their offspring don't
last over evolutionary time.
We protected our offspring because
they contain 50% of our genes,
but there's not the
psychological explanation.
Nobody but a deranged psychologists
would ever answer, Oh,
I love my children because
they contain 50% of my genes.
Rather the psychological
explanation is a deeper is is,
is different and has a different texture
and this will be a lot clearer when we
talk about the emotions where you could
really see a distinction between the
question of why we feel something from
an evolutionary point of view and why we
feel it from a day to day point of view.
The second misconception is that natural
selection tales that everything is
adaptive. That everything we do,
everything we think is it that adaptive,
this is wrong.
Um,
natural selection evolution more generally
distinguished between adaptations and
byproducts and accidents.
Many of you are currently
our will as you get older,
suffer back pain.
If I was asking,
so why do you suffer back pain?
How does back pain help you survive
and reproduce? Well answers.
It's not an adaptation.
Back pain is an accidental byproduct
of how our backs are shaped.
Don't go looking for an adaptive reason
for hiccups or self pity or bloating
after you eat.
There's all sorts of things a body
will do that have no adaptive value,
rather just accidents. We have a
body that does all sorts of things.
Some things that we'll do by accident and
this is certainly true for psychology.
Um,
so a lot of the things for
instance that occupy our interests,
our fascination in day to day life are
almost certainly evolutionary accidents.
Um,
the number that the three,
three of the main preoccupations
of humans are pornography,
television and chocolate.
But,
but if I asked you, you know, why
do you like porn? And you say,
because my ancestors who liked porn and
reproduce more than those who didn't,
just not true.
Rather you like porn,
assuming you do, um, as an accident,
you have evolved. For instance,
for instance, should you
be a heterosexual male,
you have evolved to be attracted to in it.
That is most likely to be an evolutionary
adaptation because being attracted to
women and wanting to have sex with women
is one step to the road to having kids,
which is very good from an
evolutionary perspective.
It's so happens though in our
modern environment that um,
that people have created
images that substitute.
So instead of actually going
out and seeking out women,
you can just surf the web for hours and
hours and watch dirty movies and read 30
books. Evolutionary adaptive,
dead ends there. Accidents.
Why do you like chocolate bars?
Assuming that you do it is not because
your ancestors in the African Savannah
who enjoyed chocolate bars reproduce
more than those who didn't.
Rather it is because we've evolved the
taste for sweet things and we've evolved
as taste for sweet things in part
because the sweet things in our natural
environment like fruit, we're good
for us in modern, in a modern world,
we have created things like chocolate,
which are not so good for us,
but we eat anyway.
A lot of the debates,
there's a lot of controversy in
psychology over the scope of evolutionary
explanations and a lot of the debate
tends to be over what's an adaptation and
what isn't. There are some clear
cases. We have color vision.
Why do we have color vision?
Well,
I think everybody would agree we have
color vision as an adaptation because of
the advantages it gives us for seeing
and making visual distinctions. Um,
we are afraid of snakes. We're going
to talk about that in more detail,
but there was a straightforward
adaptive story about that. Um,
we are afraid of snakes because really
our ancestors who weren't afraid of
snakes didn't reproduce as
much as those that work. Um,
we like chocolate bars
and we enjoy NASCAR.
Those are cannot be adaptations
because chocolate bars in NASCAR,
our recent developments that could not
have been anticipated by evolution.
Those are easy questions. Here
are some hard questions. Music
everywhere in the world,
people like music.
Is this an adaptation for some selective
advantage or is it an accident?
Um, Steven pinker who wrote the language
instinct that you read before, um,
caused a huge amount of controversy
when he argued that music is just an
evolutionary accident.
He described it as auditory cheesecake,
something we like to gorgeous selves on
that have no as no adaptive advantage.
Other people argue music does
have an adaptive advantage.
Sometimes males used
violence to coerce sex.
Is Male sexual violence a biological
adaptation or is it an accident?
There's more than one language.
Is that just an accidental byproduct of
the way language works or is there some
sort of group or selectionist advantage
sketched out in some way of having
multiple languages? What about
visual art? What about fiction?
What about our love for stories?
Those are all matters of heated debate.
And so we have to keep in mind
some things plainly are accidents.
Some things almost certainly aren't
accidents where the action is.
And the study of psychology in the
study of evolution of cognition, um,
is trying to figure out which is which.
So those are the misconceptions
we have to avoid. But still,
who cares? I mean, again, this is
an introduction to psych course.
Why are we talking about evolution?
Why should it matter to a psychologist?
How the mind has evolved?
I'm going to talk about evolution now,
but for rest of course I'm just
interested in how our minds are period.
So why would evolution matter
how many people think it doesn't?
Um, for instance, um, and they think
it does and for different reasons.
One claim is a metaphysical one.
You might be a dualist,
you might reject the idea. You've mental
life is the product of your brain.
And hence evolution is irrelevant to
psychology because the brain and the mind
cause the brain which may have evolved
has nothing interesting to do with the
mind. Lisa Simpson got it wrong. Um,
when she said the pope,
he got it half right when she said the
pope favorite evolution. It is true.
John Paul the second,
many years ago made a statement
saying that Darwinian theory,
um,
is not incompatible.
Darwinian theory is a view about the
evolution of species that is not motivated
by any animus,
is a genuine scientific theory.
And should it turn out to be
true? Um, it is not incompatible.
The truth about man,
as taught by the church and scientists
were thrilled by this and they were,
they said he's endorsing evolution.
What would a fewer people talk about
is the fact that after he said this,
he drew the line.
He allowed for evolution of the body,
but he would not allow for evolution
of the mind. So it was you wrote,
if the human body takes us origin
from preexisting living matter,
the spiritual soul is immediately
created by God. Consequently,
theories of evolution,
which considering the mind is emerging
from the forces of living matter or as a
mere epi phenomenon, his matter are
incompatible to truth about men.
So you might not want evolution to be
true about the mind because you might
believe that the mind is not subject to
the same physical laws as the rest of
the physical world. That's one way you
could reject evolutionary psychology.
Another way to reject evolutionary
psychology is to accept that the mines a
physical thing,
but then argue that all of these instincts
and he's hardwired facets of human
nature might exist for other animals,
but they don't exist for people.
So to anthropologists,
Ashley Montagu in 73 close
to when the $6 million man,
let me show him by the way,
said with the exception of the reactions
and infants a sudden withdrawals of
support and a sudden loud noises.
The human being is entirely instinct.
Less man is man cause he has no instincts
because everything he is and has
become,
he has learned from his culture for nomad
and made part of the environment from
other human beings. Um,
you might say, look,
he couldn't believe that in 74,
but of course all of the infant studies
that have come out since then, um,
suggested that's not true and
nobody would believe that nowadays.
But in fact the view was
often hold health. Um,
Louis Banana in a New Yorker article a
few years ago wrote every aspect of life
has a biological foundation
in exactly the same sense,
which is that unless it was biologically
possible, it wouldn't exist. After that,
it's up for grabs.
And this is in the context of an argument
that evolution can tell us anything
about what's most interesting
about people, man does not,
is an educated intelligent scholar.
He is presumably well aware of the
findings of spell key and by our general
about how people are hardwired
to understand objects and
social life and so on.
But his point is just that when it
comes to the more interesting aspects of
human nature,
the stuff we're naturally intuitively
interested in that's more cultural and
evolutionary theory and Darwinian theory
was just doesn't have anything much to
say about it.
Not because the mind is separate from the
brain but just because humans are much
more cultural organisms.
And so biology has little to say about it.
Um,
there's a third objection
which is you might think, okay,
the human mind actually
does contain instincts. We,
there is a human nature but we should
just study it by studying people.
How good evolution,
the study of evolution to consideration
revolution tell us anything interesting.
Um,
I actually in my own work think evolution
can tell us some interesting things
and I want to try to make a case for
ways in which evolution can inform and
enlighten us about the mind as it is.
First I want to make a point which is,
um,
although this course is intro psych and
it is about the mind as it is still,
I think by any account, the evolution
of consciousness, morality and so on,
just as is intuitively interesting.
Um,
it's the sort of thing that people are
just fascinated by and I think it's a
question of interest in
and of its own right.
But here's how it could tell us
about psychology. For one thing,
it can tell us what,
what can be innate and what cannot.
So some problems,
some evolutionary problems have been
around for a long time and could lead to
special biological adaptations.
If I told you there was a biological
adaptation for talking made selection,
childcare, maybe it's true, maybe
it isn't, but it's not crazy.
From an evolutionary point of view,
it's a reasonable possibility that it is.
Other problems are recent and our brains
could not be specialized to deal with
them. Um, written
communication, interacting with
strangers, driving your car,
playing chess.
If you were to argue that there's a part
of the brain devoted to playing chess,
I would say you're utterly wrong.
You can not be right because from
an evolutionary point of view,
there could be no such part of the
brain evolve because playing chess as a
recent innovation as a result of focus
on evolution could help discipline us to
make coherent claims about what is
built in and what isn't built in.
Third, we're going to talk about
human differences. In this course,
we're going to devote a class to human
differences of a sort of what makes you
different from her,
different from her.
Why do we have different intelligences in
his class? Why are some of US arrogant?
And some of us humble,
some of us like attracted to men,
others attracted to women and so on.
But there's also questions
of group differences and
evolutionary theory can help
us say intelligent things about what sort
of group differences you should expect.
Because evolutionary theory predicts
that some population should evolve in
different ways than others.
The most obvious example is that,
um,
children should it be
different from adults.
The evolutionary problems faced by
a child are very different from an
evolutionary problems faced by an adult.
And you can make specific and rather
interesting predictions about how
children's brains should different
differ from adults brains.
Evolutionary theory predicts,
um,
does not make any predictions about
racial differences or ethnic differences.
Some might exist,
but there's no adaptive reason why humans
who have evolved in different parts of
the world should have profound
differences, inner mental capacities.
What does evolutionary theory
say about sex differences? Well,
it says some interesting things and we're
going to devote a class to discussing
them.
But what I think is going to be true,
proved to be important is that we'll be
able to use evolutionary biology to talk
sensibly about what sort of
distinctions between the sexes,
between males and females one would
expect to find and what sort one wouldn't
expect to find. We can make educated
predictions. I'm going to have,
I want to put here a clip of a man.
This is a scene from a movie,
the movie Roger Dodger that begins of
a man making quasi evolutionary claims,
but the difference you men and women.
And I want to put this as an example
of where you could call bar room
evolutionary psychology.
And,
and I want to us to hold us in our minds
because it's going to return to these
claims and disgust or validity.
I like this for a few reasons.
First,
I liked that the backward reference to
William James and utility. Um, second,
it is a gorgeous combination of some
things that are actually reasonably
rational and total bull crap. Um, and,
and but what evolutionary biology will
give us is the tools to distinguish
between the two, like on the face of it
immediately, the ability to read maps,
to claim it as a biological,
that differences not ability
have a biological roots is crazy.
And the other hand, the claim that one
that that males may develop a trait,
not because it's advantageous,
but to attract females is less crazy.
The telepathic stuff is really crazy,
but so I'm not at this point
when a devoted lecture to sex,
I'm not at this point want to make
any claims one way or another.
But what I want to suggest is that
from a biological point of view,
we could say sensible and an intelligent
things about what differences should
exist and what shouldn't.
Finally, and most of all,
looking at something from the perspective
of design directive of what's it for
can often give you interesting
insights as to its current nature.
And I'll give you two quick examples.
One that's not from psychology,
one that is um,
women suffer.
Often women who are pregnant early
in her pregnancy suffer from morning
sickness, nausea, throwing up and so on.
This is traditionally been viewed as
of just a breakdown in the system.
Too much hormones, everything's
a skew. Women get nauseous.
Margie profit,
um,
suggested an alternative and this one her
to MacArthur genius award and this was
the claim that maybe pregnancy
sickness is not an accident. Rather,
it's designed,
it has a biological purpose in particular
as the baby develops in the uterus,
it is vulnerable to various
sorts of poisons are to ratigans.
Um,
profit suggested that pregnancy sickness
is a hyper sensitive period where women
are extremely sensitive,
get extremely nauseous towards the sorts
of foods that could damage their baby.
Now if it's,
you just ended there to story,
how do we know it's true?
But then she went on to examine it the
same way that any scientist examines any
claim by making predictions
and testing them.
And this makes them
interesting predictions.
It suggests the timing of
onset and offset of pregnancy,
sickness of morning sickness.
It should correspond to the period of
maximum vulnerability on the part of the
developing embryo or fetus suggested a
types of foods avoided should correspond
to those sorts of foods that were most
deadly for the fetus and that were deadly
for the fetus during the
periods where humans evolve.
This last qualification
is an important one.
Women do not develop an aversion
to alcohol during pregnancy.
Even though alcohol is extremely
dangerous to the developing child,
the answer is an easy one. Alcohol wasn't
around during our evolutionary history.
And we can not have evolved a system to
protect ourselves from it. And finally,
there should be a relationship
between miscarriage and birth,
birth defects in a surprising direction
for profit.
And she has evidence to back this up.
Um,
pregnancy sickness is not
a glitch in the system.
Rather it's the sign of a healthy,
active protective mechanism going on.
And in fact,
the more prep morning sickness,
the more the baby should be protected.
Something which by and
large appears to be true.
That's an example of how the question
when dealing with, they say, Hey, women,
throw up when they get
pregnant and then say, look,
maybe that's not just a glitch.
What's it for?
You could then learn
some interesting things.
Here's a different example
based on the last lecture,
this wonderful lecture by Peter Salivate
on sex and love where he talked about
the big three.
These are the big three to remind you
of what attracts us to somebody else.
Um, you're very attracted to the person
next to you or a person that because
proximity, similarity, familiarity,
and there is abundant evidence
supporting the truth of this.
It's almost always true,
but in evolutionary psychologist looks
at this and says there's something
seriously wrong here.
There's some cases where that has
to be totally, absolutely mistaken
to, to realize what does
is think for a moment,
what humans are you most close to,
most similar to and familiar with.
What humans did you spend over 10 years
of your life with who are genetically
and environmentally as close
to you as if they were related,
who you are intimately familiar with.
Are those the humans that
you find the hottest?
Now they're your siblings
and they are not hot.
Why was I was on Google
images this morning.
I put it up some hot siblings.
Um,
and but,
but although we may find them hot,
they do not typically with some
rare and bizarre exceptions,
find one another hot.
Why not?
Well,
this is not a huge puzzle from the
standpoint of evolutionary biology.
Evolutionary biology posits that humans
as well as other animals should have
incest avoidance. We should
like, we should be attracted
to those familiar to us,
similar to us,
close to us,
but not kin kin are off limits.
There's a good reason why,
um,
because if you intermate with your kin,
you have bad offspring
and so animal should be wired
up not to meet with their kin.
And in fact, this is,
this is what happens. Um,
there are parents of teenagers have
all sorts of concerns and a lot of the
concerns are in fact sexual.
Um,
how do you keep your son
and or your daughter from
going out and having sex with
too many people are the wrong
people or unprotected sex,
but there are no parenting guides in
the world and say, how do you keep your,
your,
your children having sex with one another?
You typically do not need to because
they do not want to have sex with one
another.
Um,
now this is actually also illustrates
differently in proximate and ultimate
causation. So you think for yourself,
Ooh, do I want to have sex with my sister?
You don't think to yourself,
I would prefer not to confer for the
offspring that we will create or be
non-viable and it'll be a waste of my
reproductive efforts. Rather you think,
Ooh, because at a gut
level you respond. Um,
and this sort of instinctive response
is what you get from an evolutionary
analysis of sex.
But this story is deeply
incomplete because the question
that gets raised is how
do you tell,
you don't want to have sex with your kin,
but how do you tell your kid people
don't carry their DNA markers,
uh, on strips that you could see.
How do you tell who your Kinnar,
and this actually turns out to
be a really interesting question.
It used and some research suggests
that the answer is simple.
You will avoid sex with
people you grew up with.
And these studies actually
come from Kibbutz Studies, um,
studies where people are raised
communally on an Israeli kibbutz.
They know they're not related,
but it's still a fact that they
were raised together as kids. Um,
suggests that is a queue at a gut level,
not to be attracted to one another.
It turns out for some reason now to
believe this story is incomplete. Um,
a paper that came out in nature five
days ago reported a series of extremely
interesting studies and they found that
the cue of being raised together as a
child with somebody, yes, that
does diminish sexual desire,
but an even bigger Q was did
you observe your parents?
And in particular your mother taking
care of that person if you did that
seriously diminished in sexual desire and
brings it down to the level of disgust.
And again,
these are the sorts of questions and
issues you begin to ask when you approach
things from an evolutionary
perspective.
Okay.
Um,
for this lecture,
the rest of this lecture,
and then the next couple of lectures
I'll be discussing some basic aspects of
human nature that are to some extent or
another informed by evolutionary theory.
And what I want to start for the remainder
of this lecture is a discussion of
rationality.
Now,
some of you maybe not want
to go into evolution, not,
not wanting to go into psychology because
there's no Nobel prize for psychology.
You might all think, hey, if I'm
going to go into the sciences,
I won a Nobel prize.
Think how proud bubby and 80 would be.
If I want to Nobel prize. Well
then that'd be the best. Um,
you can get one.
Um,
psychologists have won the Nobel prize.
Most recently,
Danny Kahneman won a Nobel prize. You
win an economics, sometimes medicine,
not a big deal.
Um,
he wanted for his work done over
the course of many decades on human
rationality.
And this work was done in collaboration
with Amos Tversky who, uh,
who passed away several years ago.
Um,
and this work entirely transformed the
way we think about human decision making
and rationality. Condiment and first
ski caused a revolution in economics,
psychology,
and the social sciences more generally
by causing us to shift from the idea that
we're logical thinkers who think in
accord with the axioms of logic and
mathematics and rationality.
More towards the idea that we actually
have sort of rough and ready heuristics.
These horistic served as well during
the time during our evolutionary,
but sometimes they can lead us astray.
And I want to give some examples of
these Horace sticks and I'll give four
examples of heuristics that are
argued to permeate our reasoning.
The first is framing effects. This was
a classic study by Kahneman and Tversky.
Um,
involving this sort of question
us is preparing for the outbreak of a
disease is going to kill 600 people.
There are two programs,
program a,
if you follow a 200 people will be saved.
Program B,
there's a one third chance everybody
won't be saved and a two third chance
nobody will be saved.
Who would choose program be?
Okay,
who would choose program?
Hey,
hi and that fits the responses.
Most people choose program a.
That's could go either way.
What's interesting is if you frame
the question differently like this,
you get very different responses.
Instead of focusing on the
people who will be saved,
you focused on the people who will die
and instead of focusing on the chance
that nobody will die and she
has every all I flip it around,
you get a corresponding flip and
this is known as a framing effect.
The idea of a framing effect is that you
can respond differently to a situation
depending on how the options are framed.
And in particular,
this combines with loss aversion.
People hate a certain loss.
4,000 of these people will die,
is extremely aversive.
And so the framing can influence your
decisions and clever advertisers and
clever decision makers will frame
things in different ways. Um,
to give you,
give rise to different intuitions.
Sometimes it could be
fairly simple. So, um,
so you have this ad have a hamburger,
it's 80% fat free versus 20% fat.
You don't have to be a
brilliant ad executive to
figure out which one to go for.
Um, it turns out that this sort of, um,
fundamental act,
the fundamental role of framing
effects is not limited to humans.
So I want to take a second and tell you
some work done by my colleague Laurie
Santos with capuchin monkeys.
And what she does is she takes these
capuchin monkeys and she teaches them to
use money.
She teaches them to use little discs to
by themselves either pieces of banana or
pieces of apple and they like to eat
this and they very quickly learn.
You can hand over a desk to
get some banana or some apple.
Now Dr. Santos and her colleagues have
done many studies using this method for
the study I'm interested in
illustrating here shows framing effects.
It needs nonhuman primates,
so what she does is there's
two options and one option.
The experiment or shows,
one object to the capuchin and low and
then either gives one or two half the
time,
gives one half the time,
give us two for an
average of one and a half.
The other experimenter does
exactly the same thing,
gives one or two for an
average of one and a half.
What starts off displaying
too now if you were a human,
how would you feel about
these two experimenters?
They both give you the same amount and
capuchins are extremely sensitive to how
much they get,
but it turns out as predicted.
They don't like the pink
experiment because the big
experimenter is it gives you
two shows you two and half
the time he gives you one.
This guy shows you one,
half the time gives you two and over
time they develop a preference for the
experiment or it shows them one initially
suggesting that they are being subject
to framing effects or choices
relative to reference point.
A different sort of demonstration
is the endowment effect.
This is a robust and
very interesting effect.
Here's the idea.
I show you something like a cup
or a chocolate bar and I say,
how much will you give me for this
chocolate bar? What was your pretty hard,
how much are you give me for
this chocolate bar? You say, Oh,
I'll give you $2 for the chocolate bar.
Both people on average give
to the big chocolate bar,
give us $2 per chocolate bar.
The other conditions exactly the same
except I hand you a chocolate bar and say,
how much money will you sell me? That
chocolate bar for their people say, ah,
two 50 and in fact,
what happens is once you own something,
it's value shoots up and this is
mystified economists and psychologists,
it makes no sense.
The chocolate bar does even have to move.
I just leave it on the table and
say either how much will you spend?
How much will you give me for
this? Or okay, it's yours.
How much you want me to take it back?
The answer is it's framing.
If you're asking how much you
want for it, it's a game. It just,
how much will you pay to get something?
But if he, if you're being asked,
how much do you want for
me to take it from you?
You treat it as a loss and as a
loss it becomes more valuable.
Those are framing effects.
The second example is base rates.
70 lawyers, uh, sorry,
70 engineers and 30 lawyers
and John's chosen at random.
Let me tell you about John. 40 years old,
married three children, conservative,
cautious, no interest in
politics, awkward around people.
His hobbies include carpentry,
sailing,
and solving mathematical
puzzles like online dating. Um,
what do you think John is a lawyer or
an engineer who thinks he's a lawyer?
Good. Who thinks he's an engineer? Okay.
Most people think he's an engineer. But
here's the thing. You switch it, right?
30 engineers, 70 lawyers.
It doesn't change people.
No matter what this number is,
these numbers,
it doesn't seem to change who you
think he is or how confident you are.
People look at John as an individual
and they ignore the background status of
where he came from.
They ignore base rates.
Base rates are very
difficult to think about.
And I want to give you an example of this.
Um,
and the, the example will be on the
slides for when you print them out,
print it out because you might
want to work through it yourself.
But I'll give this to you quickly.
Um,
there's a disease that hits one in a
thousand people, pretty common disease.
There's a test for the
disease and if you have it,
it's going to tell you you have it.
It tests for a certain thing
in your blood and boom,
if the thing is in your blood to
test, we'll go boom. If you have it,
it will tell you you have it doesn't
miss. On the other hand, it's not perfect.
It as a false positive rate of 5% so
if you don't have the disease 5% of the
time, the task will say
you have it. So you know,
if the test says you, you
don't have it, you're fine.
But it's that says you have
it, maybe have it, but maybe,
maybe it's a false positive.
You take the test says you have to
detect the disease without pen and paper.
How likely do you think dogs are?
Do you have a disease
who says over 50%
okay,
before people sinisterly shouted the
right answer. Um, people will tend,
medical students were given us
medical students less savvy than you,
and the average is between 50% and 95%.
The answer is that some people quickly
noted 2% and here's how it works.
One person out of a thousand,
we'll have the disease.
That person will test positive
tests never misses. That leaves 909,
nine people who don't have the disease.
And we'll say about 50% of these
people have it. So for every 51,
people who test positive,
only one will happen to cease
giving an average of about 2%.
This sort of thing is very difficult.
Our minds are not evolved to do base
rate computation. And so any problems,
base rate competition,
including real world problems like what
to do when you come back with a positive
test,
um,
we screw up and often we screw
up into direction of panic.
The third bias is the availability bias.
And this is simply that if you want
to know how frequent something is,
how available it is to come
to mind is an excellent queue.
Okay?
But this could lead to mistakes.
A classic example by condom a is you
ask people one group of people how many
English words and with n,
g
or what proportion of English words,
another group of people,
what proportion and with ing
turns out you get much bigger numbers
for ing than ng though of course.
AndG has to g sorry,
ng would include everything with ing.
It's just a lot easier to
think about these things.
Okay.
This can show up in real world.
What are your risk of getting killed?
What's your risk of getting
killed by a shark? Well,
if you ask people what their risk
of getting killed by a shark is,
they characteristically overestimated,
I will give you the news of what the
risk is for getting killed by a shark
injured.
Um,
in any given year one and 6
million killed one in 500 million.
If you live in Florida,
which apparently is shark central,
your chance of getting injured is
it about one and a half million
people will overestimate the risks
because shark attacks are very salient.
There always reported in the
news and are very interesting.
What is the chance of getting
killed by potato salad?
Well, food poisoning, death by food
poisoning, injury by food poisoning,
runs to about one in 55 one in 800 for
some sort of injury and one in 55,000
killed potato salad is one
1000 more times dangerous,
more dangerous than shark attacks.
But you get it wrong because you don't
think, oh my God, big news story.
Somebody dies by potato salad.
And so we tend to over estimate the
chance of being killed by dramatic facts.
How many Jews United States,
what proportion?
Who thinks it's over three quarters?
The United States is Jewish.
I'm kind of anchoring here.
Okay, okay. Who thinks over half?
Yeah.
Who thinks over 40% who
thinks over 20% okay,
who thinks over 15%
okay,
who thinks over 10% who thinks
over seven and a half percent?
Who thinks over 5% hey,
who thinks overall there's more than
5% of the United States is Jewish?
Okay.
Who thinks over 3%
dancer is somewhere between 1.9 and 2.1%.
Most people think the average
American thinks is 20% service.
Um, if you're curious about
demographics and, and this map is,
and to be entirely trusted cause
I got it from Wikipedia. Um, um,
this is the district,
this is the distribution of the Jewish
population self identified as Jewish and
different parts of United States.
Um,
New York City is of course the
most dense population with 9%.
Um,
new haven
has 3.5%.
Now why do people get it wrong?
Well,
there's all sorts of reasons and this
is going to come out in the context of
social psychology when we talk about how
people think about human groups. But,
but one quick answer is people who
are plainly Jewish are prominent in,
in positions where people notice them,
like entertainment or in the
case of have you guys academia?
And this could lead to our
dis availability. Can I
think of a Jew? Yeah. Um,
this availability
causes us to over estimate the proportion
to which Jews are represented in the
population. Final example.
Confirmation bias.
This is a very nice study.
Um, it's very simple. It's a,
you're the jury of a custody case.
You have to,
you have to give a child custody's a
either a mother or father sole custody.
One parent has average income,
average health, average working hours,
reasonable report for a child and a
relatively stable Saltzer chosen life.
Second parent has an above average income,
minor health problems,
lots of work related travel,
a very close relationship with
the travel with the child,
and an extremely active social life.
Think for a moment.
Who would you award custody with?
There's no,
obviously there's no right answer here.
Just just think for a moment.
Who would award custody to a parent?
A.
Okay.
Who would award custody to parent B?
As I think there is in this room,
um, when this study is done,
there's a slight advantage to parent B.
Here's what's interesting. You give
another group of people this question,
which parent would you deny custody to?
You get a slight advantage for parent B.
Now,
this is to some extent an
illustration of framing problems,
but it's also more general
illustration of the confirmation bias.
So when you're asked to award custody to
use instant ask, well, where's a good,
where's the sign that
someone is a good parent?
And the good parent aspects of
be jump out when asking what?
Deny custody. You ask where's acute
at somebody, he's a bad parent.
And the bad parent
aspects, uh, be jump out.
In general, when we have a
hypothesis, we look for confirmations.
This makes some things
which are logically easy,
extremely difficult problems when
you face them in the real world.
And I'll end with my final example
that of the waste in selection task.
Here's the game and people, I don't want
people to shout it out just yet. Um,
there's four cards.
Each card has a letter on one side
and a number on the other side.
You have to judge whether
this claim is true or false.
Um,
if a card has a d on one side,
it has a three on the other side.
How many cards you have to turn over
to test whether that rule is right.
Okay. Somebody shout out what one
card is. You have to turn it over.
D everybody gets that right?
What else do you need to do?
Any other cards?
How do people think it's, it's D in
three. I'm raising my hand to foil.
People answer either d or d and three,
but think about it.
What would make this rule wrong?
It's wrong of as d on one side
and not three another, right?
That's what it would be to be wrong.
You then look after to check d to see
if there's a three and others hide.
You will write about that.
Did need to check eight to see
if there's a d on the other side.
Three is not that tell you anything
that's hard.
People find this very
hard. Okay, big deal.
But what's interesting is you can modify
it in certain ways to make it a lot
easier. And this is the work of leader
caused meetings in her colleague,
an evolutionary psychologist
as Santa Barbara,
who has argued that if you frame these
questions in ways that makes ecological
sense,
people are much better at them.
And basically she does studies where she
has people who are evaluating a social
rule.
Imagine these cards on one side of
the card is an alcohol is a drink.
Uh,
on the other side is the person's age.
You are a bartender and you want to
make sure nobody under 21 drinks beer,
which cards you turn over.
Okay,
well now it's easier,
but the logic is the same.
It's a violation that was under 21 on
one side or another side. So you need to,
to check the under 21 here.
I need to check the beer here.
And when you make these logical
problems more ecologically valid,
they turned out to be much easier.
Okay.
Um,
there's a little bit more,
but I'll hold it off till next class
and I'll end with the reading response,
which used to do your own bit of
reverse engineering and evolutionary
psychology.
And I'll see you all on Wednesday.